a court in beijing has thrown out what
was being called a landmark case brought
by a woman who said she was sexually
assaulted by a chinese tv celebrity
twenty-eight-year-old joshua accused tv
host jujun of attacking her in 2018 when
she was an intern at state broadcaster
cctv he denied the charges and sued joe
for defamation feminists fear the
court's decision will deal another blow
to china's fledgling metoo movement and
leave female victims of male violence
unsure where to turn
this was the day accuser joe xiao schwen
had been waiting for for more than three
years
she knew it would be a make or break
moment
before heading into the hearing she
warned her supporters that the decision
could go either way
but she said it would have been worth it
regardless of the outcome
in the end what i want to say is no
matter whether it results in joy or
agony i'm very honoured to have gone
through this together with everyone
security was tight outside the
police cordoned off the street to
prevent crowds gathering as they had at
a first hearing last december
officers confiscated a sign from one
protester saying stand together
and intimidated others
by filming them
joe admits that the experience has taken
an emotional toll on her
it's been more than three years since
she went public with her allegations
that prominent tv host jujun groped her
and used force to kiss her when she was
an intern at state broadcaster cctv in
2018
and he was her superior
she sued him for damages but he launched
a countersuit alleging she had destroyed
his reputation
after this second hearing the court
rejected her case saying she did not
have enough evidence to prove her boss
had sexually assaulted her
but her supporters said the odds were
stacked against her from the start
because victims of male sexual violence
rarely get the support they need in
china so women are still being hunted
down or still prey
the women's rights has not been
as well established established in china
as um
as in western countries
joe has said she will appeal the court's
decision
when she does interest is likely to be
great
both in and outside of china
yachu wang is a china researcher at
human rights watch and joins me now from
new york ms wang are you surprised that
the case against jujun was thrown out
well i don't think i am surprised
because the court has already stole
uh
uh prevented uh uh shenzhen from you
know submitting uh uh
more evidence from uh you know gathering
evidence uh from uh camera and things so
there are already indications that the
case wasn't in a good shape
now you're talking about evidence such
as uh the security camera footage of the
workplace where this harassment took
place and then the accused juju not even
being required to come to court to try
and testify i mean therefore for me the
question really is do you think china's
legal system is tilted against women who
make complaints about sexual harassment
i absolutely i think so
uh you know why shouldn't jujin be
somebody to testify in the court uh you
know is in clear indication that you
know it's very very hard for women to uh
sue for sexual harassment if the court
system doesn't you know put a weight on
personal accounts on personal
testimonies and there are any
other things that in the system that
make it's very hard for women to you
know go through the process and win the
case but why is that the case in china
well i think you know it's just like in
any other countries it's a patriarchal
countries that you know it's harder for
women to
uh you know uh
gain
you know redress through the court
system because well i mean just like in
many other countries the laws are
written by
men and you know the judge is a man and
the lawyer is a man
but at the same time you have
the same country china which also passed
sexual harassment legislation last year
last month well-known singer chris wu
was arrested on suspicion of rape so i'm
just wondering what is the message here
from the government are women's rights
important or aren't they
well i think the message really is that
you know china the chinese government
wants uh
uh you know social stability stability
is most important thing rather than you
know women's rights are important
because after the case was thrown out of
court the chinese government start to
censor uh social media posts about the
case whether your pro students or your
entitlements uh both sides messages are
censored which says the united
government doesn't want you to talk
about it don't make a fuss you know
let's just go uh
go by our lives without you know
demanding for rights uh so you know
that's just the chinese government's
message is it the case also that the
chinese government decides when to act
and people follow the chinese
government's lead and not people
themselves
absolutely that's absolutely because i
mean in both in you know both chris wu's
case and also the alibaba a sexual
assault case the government acted uh
fast it's not like the government wasn't
doing anything it's just that the
government wants to do something and
the government wants to shut you up and
so you know let's just move on that's
the message
where does uh joe shelton's case being
thrown out leave china's metoo movement
well i think you know
the case has garnered so much attention
it's very important and i think it's
definitely uh the whole me to move and
made progress the people who didn't pay
attention now uh is paying attention to
sexual harassment and agenda issues
and the
you know the victims who were used to
be reluctant to speak up and now
speaking up they feel you know
emboldened
encouraged by the schwan's case so i
think those are definitely uh you know
progress
yah chu wang from human rights watch
thank you so much for joining us today
thank you for having me